there was the Google memo that went out
as they are calling it the anti
diversity manifesto now this news
developed so fast this happened after we
aired last night
Google fired the employee who wrote the
memo in record time
record time the guy just got absolutely
Canada as of this morning rumor is that
Google has already replaced the employee
in the spirit of diversity she's
actually a single black mother
transgender pansexual undocumented
immigrant with a PhD in women's studies
and she has rickets so she is a modern
marvel but she checks the boxes never
firing that they not only fired him the
CEO took time out of his vein vacation
to condemn this as though as though it
was that outlandish and that offensive
so here this is what the CEO said we
strongly support the right of Googlers
to express themselves wait for it
however portions of the memo violate our
code of conduct and cross the line by
advancing harmful gender stereotypes in
our workplace well it doesn't do that
we'll get to that in a second to suggest
a group of our colleagues have traits
that make them less biologically suited
to that work is offensive and like a
fourteen-year-old girl he says not okay
all caps because that's how you talk to
an actual misogynist or an actual
Klansmen that's not okay bro okay it's
not cool dude you're please bro to rape
it's not okay I highly recommend that
people go and now it's out there read
the full memo for context don't take our
word for it
this is what he goes out of his way and
ben shapiro highlighted this too in the
original memo you tell me if this is
gender stereotypes I'm not saying that
all men differ from all women in the
following ways or that these differences
are just I'm simply stating with a
distribution of preferences and
abilities of men and women differ in
part due to biological causes and that
these differences may explain what we
don't see equal representation of women
in tech and leadership many of these
differences are small and there's
significant overlap between men and
women so you can't say anything about an
individual given these population level
distributions and this is this is what
really bothers me when they say he just
she just condemns women and says they're
not fit no actually he he lists some
areas where men might naturally be more
effective than women not all as he just
said but on the whole you know on
average and then he goes on to
the qualities that women would naturally
have our areas where women would
naturally excel at over men like women
in his own mo women on average show a
higher interest in people and men in
things that's a that's a good thing
women on average are more cooperative
and then here's something subject it if
you think it's it's good or bad I would
say good women on average look for more
work-life balance while men have a
higher drive for status on average go
back to the CEO he says the memo has
clearly impacted our co-workers some of
whom are hurting and feel judged based
on their gender so just see this this
memo it's incredible was so
earth-shatteringly offensive that some
women at Google took a sick day
the women were so offended that the memo
insinuated they might handle stressful
situations more emotionally that they
decided work was too stressful to attend
a woman I'm more likely to take a sick
day I'm punching out but call it my sick
day I just that's why you're seeing ads
for Muslim singles because these are the
women in charge of our housing
algorithms
hey could you put something relevant to
the search no I can't
somebody said my thighs look big in
these pants hey what was the restricted
vote algorithm 16 year-olds are seeing
x-rated films don't bother me right now
I feel fat let's assume for a second
that Google and YouTube is earnest when
they fly us out to New York to have our
meetings in our summits and they say
they don't want to boot right-wingers
they say that they want to be friendly
differing opinions they say that they
want to be a friendly environment to
conservatives and liberals like let's
assume that that's all true take it at
face value okay here's the question
would they be able to recognize their
blind spots would they be able that's
the crux of this argument that we're
actually having with this memo on the
firing would they be able to check their
inherent biases if they wanted to I
would argue no let me present my case
Exhibit A
Susan was shigeaki the CEO of YouTube
she's a Democrat donor promotes the
Young Turks and advocates for
transgenders in the military she's a CEO
of YouTube she's not just to let just a
liberal she's a social justice warrior
leftist she uses words like
microaggressions and trigger warnings on
ironically
be sundar Pichai pokai I see he's a CEO
of Google okay Democrat donor and of
course advocates for transgenders in the
military not sick not even saying his
opinion is wrong or that you shouldn't
or should agree with him I'm just trying
to present to you the points of view of
these people who are in charge of
everything always at Google and YouTube
let alone the rest of Silicon Valley
Exhibit C John Gianna Gianna drew see
the only consistency in the hiring is
that they have very difficult names he's
a senior VP for search at Google and a
noted Democrat donor next person Sridhar
Ramaswamy senior VP for ads and commerce
at Google huge Kamala Harris supporter
and an actual Hillary Clinton donor next
person Sergey Brin co-founder of Google
president of Google's parent company
Democrat donor gave 800,000 to a PAC
that offered free rides to polling
stations shortly before the election now
you say well that's not necessarily
right or left no of course it is because
we don't believe that people who need to
be given rides and free sandwiches to
polling stations nor have ID should
probably be voting I know that's racist
next person Chad her there's the name
YouTube co-founder there you go just a
good old white guy YouTube co-founder
and advisor noted Democrat donor next
person Danielle Brown the names are
getting easier Google's head of
diversity in a twist of irony Danielle
brown head of ever seen a Chihuahua Kiki
worked directly for Hillary Clinton's
campaign next person John Doerr Google
board member Democrats support PAC donor
and he actually held a democrat
fundraiser back to hard names Omid
cordis Donnie the former senior VP at
Google now executive chairman at Twitter
because of the incestuous Silicon Valley
relationships Democrat donor and a Trump
hater on Twitter
there's no idea of conflicts of
interests I'm sitting on the chair at
Twitter and I'm going to use it to bash
the president on Twitter finally we have
David Drummond senior VP at Google for
corporate development and he is a noted
Democrat donor here's the takeaway there
and I want you to do your own research
take a dart board take any of the senior
executives at Google Facebook or Twitter
okay place their names in a dart board
throw the dart any name you hit is going
to be not only a liberal but a far left
activist every single one now they may
be earnest they may think that they
really want to bridge the gap
they may think they really want to have
a dialogue they may think that they
really want to welcome all voices but we
see here with this letter which was very
carefully written this memo which went
out of its way to do all of the hey
listen okay to set the tone I am NOT
saying this applies across the board I
am NOT saying this is a plus or a minus
I just think we might want to discuss
the differences you're at it here so
clearly they're not looking to have a
conversation but even if they actually
were they would be incapable of it they
would they would they would be incapable
of it just pick any one anyone out there
like this video subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button it's acted sinesses
circle now it used to be a square which
most buttons aren't squares lets us on a
phone there's square buttons on phones
what mouse buttons are circles you
understand what I'm talking about or
watch the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
ladder with credit comm flash mug Club
join them on clip so you can get the
daily show and that means that you are
not beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom